bref parce qu'aujourd'hui par rapport à
la réforme de la retraite donc il ya une
suppression effectivement d'une partie
de nos postes qui sont prévues notamment
une partie de la branche retraite qui
sera transférée en métropole dans une
nouvelle caisse qui sera gérée notamment
par an certaines carences et puis
également la suppression de la
tarification dans les mois à venir et
notamment le retard qui sera
probablement mort pris par les impôts
donc effectivement on milite pour le non
au démantèlement de la sécurité sociale
et pour que l'on puisse garder nos
poches et qu'on puisse exercer donc nos
valeurs et qui ont relativement voie
tracée par le caractère social on
pouvait voir peu près 60% comme des
agents
qui pourront effectivement voir se voir
confronter un licenciement économique ou
à des ruptures conventionnelles ou
éventuellement à des mutations foncé et
ça nous disons non